ونحييكم من جديد فرنسا تضرب الاخوان في
محفظتهم عنوان تصدر صحيفه لوفيغاغو
الفرنسيه
تصدر احدث ابرز تفاصيلها وفق صحيفه ان
المديريه العامه للامن الداخلي حددت نحو
20 صندوق تبرعات مشكوك بارتباطه بالاسم
السياسي في فرنسا ووفقا لوفيغوفي فقد جرى
فعلا تجميد ما يقرب من الخمسه والعشرين
مليون يورو في مختلف صناديق التبرعات
المعلومات وفقه هذه الصحيفه تشير الى ان
الاخوان استثمروا الاموال بشكل غير قانوني
في غرف الصلاه لضمان تشغيل وصيانه المساجد
المعروفه بقربها من الحركه كما اشارت
الصحيفه الفرنسيه الى قيام منظمتين
محسوبتين على الاخوان بحل نفسيهما بعد ان
تم فحصهما بلا او بما في ذلك صندوق اكيلا
في مدينه وسط البلاد وبحسب لافيغو فان
الجماعات المرتبطه بالاسلام السياسي في
تستغل تبرعات سواء كانت في الداخل او في
الخارج لتمويل مشاريعها ونشاطاتها ابرز
الهياكل التي تم تعليقها الصندوق الاوروبي
للمراه المسلمه وصندوق الكندي وصندوق
يقول اعضاء جماعه الاخوان المسلمين الذين
تضرروا بشده من تعدد الضوابط انهم مذهولون
من فكره تخيل نضوب اموالهم موافقه الصحيفه
الفرنسيه
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من باريس
الدكتور بديل مرابطي مدير معهد الابحاث
والدراسات العليا في بروكسل اهلا بك ومن
القاهره احمد بان الباحث في شؤون الجماعات
المتطرفه اهلا بكم الكريمين واسمح لي ان
ابدا من باريس معك دكتور مرابطي دكتور
مرابطي في الواقع موضوع الجماعات وصناديق
خاصه التبرعات فرنسا موضوع كبير وحاولت كل
الحكومات الفرنسيه انتم هذا الموضوع وان
تحقق فيه ولكن تعلم حضرتك بانه المبادئ
الفرنسيه وقانون 19 05 يمنع اقتراب
الحكومات الفرنسيه من مثل هكذا مواضيعمه
ولكن هذه المره تمكنت من تجميد الاموال هل
تعتقد بان هذه خطوه اولى لفتح ملفات اعمق
واكبر واخطر في داخل الفرنسي
ليس ذلك واضحا الى حد الساعه ولكن اذا
قارن ذلك بما جرى مرات سابقه الواقع انه
في هذه الملفات عندما تتكشف وغالبا ما لا
تتكشف معطياتها الجديه الى سنوات بعد ذلك
غالبا ما تظهر خصوصا عندما تعرض على
القضاء وعندما يبث القضاء في موضوعها ثم
ياخذ سنوات تظهر غالبا انه جزء كبير من لف
هو سياسي اساسا لاستهلاك الراي العام جزء
من الملف غالبا ايضا يكون جدي ولكن يكون
جزء من الملف هو الجدي والجزء اخر هو
اساسا لاسباب تتعلق بالراي العام السياسه
الحكومه الحاليه في فرنسا بشكل خاص وزير
الداخليه الفرنسيه
تحاول او يحاول من خلالها ان يظهر بمظهر
الذي يواجه التطرف لذلك اسباب سياسيه لذلك
اسباب تتعلق بالصراعات حزبيه لذلك اسباب
تتعلق بتموقع الحكومه الفرنسيه الحاليه
لذلك اسباب تتعلق كذلك بالطم الشخصيه لبعض
اعضاء هذه الحكومه في المستقبل لانه كما
تعرفين الرئيس ماكرون لا يمكن ان يترشح
قانونيا وبالتالي هنالك حتى برصداء بعض
اعضاء حكومته بشكل خاص لدى وزير الداخليه
هذه النقاط تضاف الى قضايا اخرى تتعلق
بتحول الاجتماعي الحاصل في المجتمع
الفرنسي والحاصل في ذوي الاصول الاسلاميه
داخل المجتمع الفرنسي التاريخيا يعتبر
كثيرا من علماء الاجتماع في فرنسا بان
نقاش حول
المكونه الاسلاميه سواء كان يتعلق مثلا
بحدوث احداث عنف احد ارابيه او كان يتعلق
بشكل عام باشكاليات التعايش اليومي غالبا
ما وظفت واستخدمت اجنده السياسيه وغالبا
ايضا وظيفه تاجيل نقاشات اعماق وهم بشكل
خاص علاقه فرنسا بمستعمراتها السابقه
والتحول الذي حصل في فرنسا تجاه هذه بما
يتعلق بهذه العلاقه او هذه العلاقات في
الخمسين سنه الاخيره فالنقطه الاخيره التي
تتعلق الان
بتمويلات بلا شك انه
الضواحي باريس و بعض المدن الفرنسيه
الكبرى الاخرى
باشكالياتها الاقتصاديه وبما يتعلق باوضاع
المساجد فيها هي ايضا الصراع لعدد من
الحركات في فرنسا قراءه متعدده لذلك بعضها
قراءات يمنيه التي اليوم تحدثت
حساب خاصه بها يمينيه ولدها تصفيه حسابات
فيها الشبكات معينه ليست متفقه على شيء
بينها باستثناء ما يتعلق
بالقضيه الهوياتيه والقضيه الهوياتيه
اخذته
دكتور مرابطي فقط نقطه اخيره بهذا نقطه
فقط نقطه اخيره بهذا
النقطه الاخيره تتعلق بانه
هذه الجمعيات لديها اشكاليه ماليه جديه
ليست من الان ولكن هذه الاشكاليه الجلديه
مرتبطه بالوضعيه القانونيه للجمعيات في
مثل هذه الضواحي وهذه تتشابك فيها خصوصيه
المكونات ذات الاصل الاسلامي ذات الاصول
العربيه الاسلاميه ومكونات اخرى ربما
لديها قدره اجتماعيه وقوه اجتماعيه قد لا
تتوجه الى لا تستطيع ان تتوجه
خلينا نسال شويه عن موضوع امكانيه ان لانه
حضرتك تقول لانه صناديق التبرعات هذه هي
اساسا اهدافها اما سياسيه او اجتماعيه
تخدم الداخل تخدم الاحزاب تخدم هذه
المجموعه لم اتحدث اسف لم اتحدث عن
الصناديق بذاتها هذه الصناديق بالتاكيد لو
اضفنا فقط جمله حولها تاكيد هنالك تبرعات
كثيره ووضعيه القانونيه دائما محل اشكال
وبالتاكيد انه
وضحت فكره حضرتك ولك
اشكاليات كبيره ان تكون صناديق التبرعات
هذه لصالح الجماعه بكل ما تشمله اعمالها
داخل فرنسا او خارجها وهنا سؤال حضرتك
استاذ احمد هذه التبرعات كيف يمكن ان
تستغلها جماعه الاخوان في الداخل الفرنسي
او في الخارج
يعني تنظيم الاخوان ركم خبرات حركيه
وتنظيميه في العديد من الدول التي استطاع
ان يتماضع داخلها بعد سقوط سرديته في
العديد من الدول خصوصا في العالم العربي
والاسلامي تمثل فرنسا واوروبا بشكل عام
المكان نستطيع ان نقول محاوله لاعاده
تاسيس تنظيم الاخوان والاختباء خلف ما
يسمى بالكود الاوروبي للحقوق والحريات حيث
استطاع التنظيم ان يعيد كموضعه عبر العديد
من الواجهات عبر السيطره على الجاليات
المسلمه الى حد ان ما يسمى بمجلس المله
الاسلاميه وهو الممثل المسلمين داخل فرنسا
كان هيئه اخوانيه كامله تطلع
باجنده الاخوان وتنفذ اجنده الاخوان وربما
هذا ما دفع اداره الرئيس الفرنسي في في
اغسطس الى استبدال هذا المجلس بمجلس تم
تشكيله تحت عين الحكومه الفرنسيه لا شك ان
هذه الخطوه في تقدير خطوه مهمه الحديثه 20
صندوق يجري التحقيق من مدى
سلامه تشكيلهم قانونيا مدى وجود شفافيه
فيما يتعلق بجمع وصرف هذه الاموال اذا تمت
هذه الخطوه ونجاه مضت الى نهايتها نحن
نتحدث الان عن اربع صناديق فقط تم تجميدهم
لكن الحديث عن عشرين صندوق يدوم يضم
ملايين اليوروهات وبالتالي اذا تم تجميد
هذه الارصده سيكون ضربه كبيره لهذا
التنظيم ولموارده الماليه كما انها ستكون
خدمه كبيره للباحثين ولجهود مقاومه هذا
التنظيم بالنظر الى اننا قد نتوفر على سجل
قانوني معلوماتي يتحدث عن هذه الاوعيه
الماليه او الصندوق الاسود لتنظيم الاخوان
في الخارج والذي مكانه من الصمود طوال
محطات سابقه الان تراجع تمويل التنظيم في
العديد من الحواضن التقليديه سواء في مصر
او في العالم العربي والاسلامي وبالتالي
بقيت المحطه الاوروبيه او المساحه
الاوروبيه هي الساحه الواسعه التي يتحرك
فيها التنظيم الان هذه الخطوه التي جرت
خطوه مهمه لكن من المهم ضبط الاطار
القانوني لها وضبط الاطار التشريعي لها
لانه في النمسا على سبيل المثال كان هناك
محاوله ايضا لتطويق هذا التنظيم والتضييق
على موارده الماليه ولم يكن هذا
التدبير تدبيرا قانونيا محكما محكما كان
عدد شركات المحاماه حتى في فرنسا يبدو بان
الموضوع كذلك يتعلق بالاجراءات والقوانين
الدكتور مرابطي يقول البعض تاخرت فرنسا في
تجميد الاموال طالما هناك تحقيقات واثبتت
بعضها بان هذه الاموال يستغلها وتستغلها
جماعه الاخوان في الداخل هل تاخرت ام ان
القوانين
تمنع على الحكومه الفرنسيه او على القضاء
التدخل همم بشكل يمكن ان يفضح معاملات
الاخوان في داخل الفرنسي
اولا خلينا نكون الصرحاء الحكومه الفرنسيه
لا الحكومه الحاليه ولا السابقه والتي
قبلها لديها مشكله مباشره مع الاخوان
والحركات التي اسست مع الاخوان المسلمين
ومع الحركات الاسلاميه المحسوبه على
الاخوان المسلمين في فرنسا اتحاد منظمات
اسلاميه المحسوب على الاخوان كانت غالبا
علاقاته جيده مع الادارات الفرنسيه ولديه
قدره كبيره على
التاقلم مع الادارات الفرنسيه المتعاقبه
القراءه السائده لدى بعض
التيارات النافذه في فرنسا هي هي ان الراي
العام يمكن ان يتقبل بسهوله ربط عدد كبير
من الجمعيات التي لديهم تصفيه حساب معها
لاسباب مختلفه ليست لنفس الاسباب لاسباب
مختلفه وبعضها فعلا لدي اشكالات قانونيه
ليست جديده
الجاليه الاسلاميه في فرنسا مستواه
الاجتماع الاقتصادي هش وان كان تحسن في
السنوات الاخيره ولكنه يظل هشا وبالتالي
تظل فيها اشك
اشكاليه المطابقه او الاشكاليه اتباع
المساطر القانونيه في كثير من جمعياته
اشكاليه هشه وهذا امر تعرفه الحكومات ولكن
تعرف كيف تستخدمه في الوقت المناسب تم
التوجيه الاتهام الى عدد كبير من هذه
الجمعيات مثلا سنه 91 كذلك سنه 94 ايام
الازمه الجزائريه كذلك بعد 2001 كذلك 2003
خلال ازمه ما سمي بازمه الحجاب ثم بعد ذلك
بعد في التفجيرات الاخيره كانت تحصل دائما
ولكن الذي على كتاب تذكرين مثلا انه سنه
93 و94 صارت عدد كبير
اخرى اكيد لان الوقت لن يكفي للتذكارك فقط
ولكن الذي عندما عندما عندما يمضي الوقت
وبالتالي الان لدينا صار لدينا تجربه
طويله يعني لدينا
معك استاذ احمد استاذ احمد ان نظرنا الى
الموضوع بطريقه اجمل من فرنسا الى اي مدى
هناك صعوبه في التتبع معاملات الماليه
لجماعات متطرفه باختصار في دقيقه سمحتلي
لا شك ان اختباء التنظيم خلف واجهات
قانونيه وروابط محليه واجتماعيه بل وروابط
اكاديميه ونجاحه في تاسيس عديد من
الواجهات مثل المنظمات الشبابيه التي يعني
تتوفر على عدد كبير من الفروع يصل الى 33
فرع لاحدى هذه المنظمات يمثل تحدي كبير
لدى الاداره الفرنسيه لكن ما هو معلوم ان
الاداره الفرنسيه بدات هذه الخطوه
وخطتلوها خطوات في اتجاه اليقظه لانشطه
هذا التنظيم شكرا جزيلا لكما من باريس يا
دكتور مدير معهد الابحاث ودراسه ومن
القاهره احمد بيان الباحث في شؤون
الجماعات المتطرفه شكرا على الحضور
والسلام عليكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات